lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
obtener un poco de práctica en el primer
paso de una sustitución y así que
empecemos con un ejemplo imagina que
queremos resolver la integral indefinida
de 2 x + 1 que multiplican a la raíz de
x cuadrada más x de x
será que aquí se puede aplicar la
sustitución
y de ser así cuál sería nuestra u este
primer paso suele ser el más difícil
sobre todo para alumnos que apenas lo
están aprendiendo el paso consiste en
identificar si es adecuado utilizar la
técnica de la sustitución y también en
cómo definir de una manera apropiada a
esa o pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar
la respuesta bueno tenemos que recordar
que la sustitución 1 es tratar de
deshacer la regla de la cadena y para
eso vamos a recordar que nos dice la
regla de la cadena si tenemos una
función compuesta
deje de equis y tomamos la derivada con
respecto a x de esta expresión va a ser
igual a la derivada de la función
exterior con respecto a la función
interior entonces primero me quedaría f
prima dgt x esto por la derivada de la
función interior con respecto a x
así que al hacer una sustitución no
significa que simplemente debemos
encontrar un patrón de esta forma dentro
de la integral es decir busquemos una
función interior es decir una gtx donde
su derivada esté a su lado multiplicando
y lo vemos justo aquí si llamó a a x
cuadrada más x cuál es la derivada de
esto bueno la derivada de x cuadrada más
x es 2 x + 1 así que podemos hacer esta
sustitución si decimos que uno es igual
a x cuadrada más x entonces podemos
decir que la derivada de eu con respecto
a x es 2 x 1 y si tratamos nuestros
diferenciales como números podremos
multiplicar todo por de x lo cual es
apropiado a clint y así obtendríamos que
de 1 es igual a 2 x 1 x
x y lo interesante aquí es que si
tenemos nuestra autora cam también
tenemos de un ya que aquí tenemos 2 x 1
y por acá de x
y tal vez no sea tan usual verlo así
pero lo voy a hacer ya que muchas
personas ven el dx como parte del
operador integral así que lo voy a mover
para que sea más claro como tengo el
producto de tres cosas esto lo puedo
escribir como la integral indefinida de
la raíz de x cuadrada más x por 2 x 1 de
x
así que claramente se ve que aquí
tenemos a nuestra y por acá tenemos a
nuestra de 1 y por lo tanto podemos
describir esto como la integral de larra
y de iu porque x cuadrada más x es por d
y esta es mucho más fácil de evaluar si
te confunde un poco puede ser que sea
más fácil que la reconozcas así la
integral de un elevado al a un medio por
d porque ahora podríamos usar la inversa
de la regla de la potencia para
encontrar esta integral y no olvides que
después debes deshacer la sustitución
una vez que encuentras la anti derivada
de esta expresión es decir regresarla a
términos de x y con esto hemos terminado
hasta la próxima